what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about the uzumaki clan
which was a much requested topic on both
the southern hokage explain video and
the every uchiha explained video i said
i'd make another naruto video as soon as
the chiha video got 4 000 likes
and it got 4 000 likes real quick same
deal here
turn that like button blue share this
video with any culture naruto fans you
know
and i'll get started on the next naruto
video as soon as we hit 4 000 likes on
this one
then i'll pick one of the suggested
topics in the comment section
and do a video on that so leave a
comment and if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future naruto videos when they drop
spoilers are obviously fair game you've
been warned now without further ado
let's jump into it like the senju clan
the uzumaki clan is descended from asura
otsutsuki
the son of the sage of six paths and the
brother of the uchiha ancestor
indra otsutsuki thus the senju clan and
the uzumaki clan
share a distant blood relation and had
tended to be on good terms with each
other
in fact the first hokage's wife was a
woman from the uzumaki clan called
mito tuzumaki clan was a prominent
family from uzushiogakure
aka the hidden eddie village this
shinobi village was located in the land
of whirlpools the uzumaki were known for
their red hair and their ceiling jutsu
in addition to that they were brimming
with vitality they aged slower and lived
longer that's why their village was
known as the village of longevity their
strong life forces allowed them to
recover from greater wounds in less time
by using their chakra they could quickly
heal themselves and potentially others
their clan symbol is the spiral circle
that you'll find at the back of naruto's
jackets because the central clan
and their friends had a close
relationship with the uzumaki and their
village
when the hidden leaf village was formed
they added the uzumaki
slash uzushiogakure symbol to their flag
jackets
and elsewhere throughout the village i
find it really cool that naruto was
always wearing the symbol of his mom and
ancestors
even before he realized it however
uzushiogakure
is no more because the village was so
feared for their ceiling jutsu abilities
they were targeted and wiped out during
the era of war and unrest the survivors
fled
and dispersed throughout the land since
then konohagakure
aka the hidden leaf village has become
the home
of the uzumaki clan which includes
naruto and his family
now let's get into the individual clan
members that we know of
number one is ashina uzumaki ashina was
the leader of the uzumaki clan
when the hidden leaf village was formed
he excelled in sealing jutsu even
compared to other members of his clan
and he was said to be the forefather of
ceiling jutsu in the hidden leaf village
on to number two mito uzumaki she was
the wife of the first hokage hashirama
senju she was from
uzushiogaku before she migrated to the
hiddenly village
not only did she become hashirama's wife
she also became the first jinchuriki
of the nine-tailed fox by sealing kurama
within herself
as ajinchuriki she also possessed the
power to sense negative emotions
it is clear that the vitality and
sealing prowess of those umaki clan
members
make them especially good jinchuriki
choices for the very powerful nine tails
mito and as we'll see later naruto's
mother had particularly powerful chakra
even among the uzumaki and this powerful
chakra could suppress the nine tails
mito was a great example of the
longevity of the uzumaki clan
she was already an adult when the hidden
leaf was formed and then she went on to
live through the first three hokage
until she finally passed on the nine
tails to kushina what's more mito's hair
never turned grey
another sign of her vitality she also
had a profound impact on kushina
teaching her that even ajin churiki can
live a happy life
if they fill it with love love is what
kept kurama in check while negative
emotions would have let him overwhelm
his jinchuriki lastly mito also had a
diamond mark on her forehead just like
tsunade who is mito's descendant
for tsunade this was the strength of a
hundred seal
aka the hundred healings mark an s rank
ceiling jutsu
which continually amasses chakra until
the user chooses to release it once
released the stored chakra will amplify
the power of the user's techniques
in a big way we don't know if mitos was
just decorated
but since it's a ceiling jutsu and since
she was tsunade's ancestor
i think it's totally possible that mito
uzumaki
was able to use this op technique as
well we don't see her fight
but you can bet that she was a force to
be reckoned with in fact
she sealed the nine tails in herself
because she wanted to gain more power
for her husband so it's clear that the
two were a real power couple
next up let's look at number three
nagato aka pain
another descendant of the uzumaki clan
he was from
amegakure aka the village headed in the
reign another antagonist with an
interesting philosophy he began leading
the nuakatsuki in order to create a
peaceful world by any means necessary
ironically if it took pain and violence
to bring about peace nagato was more
than ready to dish it out
nagato had a depressing past where his
parents including his uzumaki mother
named
fuso died in order to protect him they
tried to escape when hidden leaf village
ninja
broke into their house but when they
were detected nagato's mom and dad
decided to distract the ninjas
so that their son might have a chance of
escaping unfortunately they were killed
and nagato ended up using the renagon
eyes that madara had implanted into him
to kill these hiddenly village ninjas on
a side note
not much is known about uzumaki number 4
fuso like her son nagato
she had the red hair that's
characteristic of the uzumaki clan
we know she was a nurse and provided
humanitarian aid during the second
shinobi world war
until she sacrificed her life for her
son we don't know much about fuso's
abilities so let's get back to nagato
and his abilities
as the leader of akatsuki nagato was
regarded as the strongest member
according to kabuto he was the most
powerful reincarnated shinobi aside from
an
enhanced mother ochiha himself nagato
was often viewed as being
unbeatable and when the legendary
jiraiya lost his life to pain
tsunade even said that no one but the
pervy sage could have gotten that far
against him he could even
single-handedly destroy the hiddenly
village which is crazy to think about
as usual in these videos i'll offer a
highlight of some of nagato's impressive
abilities and if you want an even more
detailed breakdown
request a video dedicated to nagato in
the description his uzumaki heritage and
renagon eyes
combine to give nagato a vast amount of
chakra to work with it is because of his
utumaki genes that he could use
another's two renagon eyes without
drawbacks against hanzo
nagato's legs were badly injured leaving
his original body frail but fortunately
for him
he had other ways to fight more on that
in a bit as with naruto jiraiya trained
nagato who mastered every technique that
was taught to him he could use all
five basic nature transformations and
yang release at the mere age of 10.
nagato is an amazing sensor able to
pinpoint a person's specific chakra from
vast distances
and figure out their location he can
also alter his own chakra
so other sensors can't discover him he
was so skilled with the renagon
that obito called him the third sage of
six paths
the renagon gave nagato access to the
six paths techniques
including gravitational powers animal
summons
chakra absorption control over people's
souls body manipulation slash
mechanization
and the ability to summon the king of
hell who can be used for interrogation
purposes or to repair
damage when he was alive he used each
one of these six
abilities through six avatars nagato
kept the ability of the outer path for
his own body which allowed him to summon
the husk of the ten tails to use black
receivers to control avatars or people
by channeling chakra into them
and to use the simsera of heavenly life
technique this last technique is a bit
of a cheat code allowing one to
sacrifice their own life energy to
revive
the recently departed nagato used this
technique to bring back many hidden leaf
ninja including kakashi
the king of hell released all the souls
which returned to their rejuvenated
bodies
and in turn nagato's red hair turned
white before he eventually expired
next up let's look at uzumaki number
five the obsessed sasuke fangirl karim
she's from kusa gakure aka the village
hidden in the grass
she was an assistant to arochimaru and
then a member of sasuke's group taka
meaning hawk
sasuke used her to perform one of the
most savage revenge moments in anime
when he shot through her in order to hit
donzo despite this karin who managed to
survive
ended up forgiving sasuke and even
delivering his and sakura's child sarada
cotton later gave sada her original
glasses so you gotta hand it to her
overall she handled losing sasuke to
sakura pretty well
now let's turn to her abilities she
wasn't chosen by oroshimaru and then by
sasuke for no reason
unlike nagato she doesn't really shine
in combat but in assistance
she possesses an ability known as the
mind's eye of the kagura which allows
her to
sense and track chakra from vast
distances she can also sense changes in
chakra which lets her know
when someone is lying or when someone is
caught in a genjutsu
she can tell when there's weird chakra
behavior within a radius of many
kilometers
so she can quickly escape before
something goes down and she can even
conceal her own chakra making her
invisible to chakra sensors
obviously as she's concealing her chakra
she can't use abilities that require
chakra
so this is an ability that should be
used when hiding rather than when
fighting
then we have her life force which is
remarkable like a true uzumaki her life
force is so strong that she can heal
others by having them bite her she often
healed sasuke in this way
and it definitely led to some weird and
funny moments kainen's life force
is ample enough to restore a heavily
damaged and depleted hokage tsunade
cutting jokes about how tsunade takes so
much of her chakra that she's going to
age into an old hag but she ends up
being fine
her life force chakra reserve and
healing powers are truly exceptional
although she unfortunately has to live
with those bite marks all over her body
we've also seen karen use those
maki clans at a man teen ceiling chains
technique the chains come from the
user's body
wrap around targets and thus restrain
them the chain's bind chakra as well as
the body
when naruto's mom uses it more on her
later
she can hold down the nine tails no
small feet notably though a naruto data
book reveals that karen's level of
mastery over the technique is nowhere
close to kushina's level of mastery we
also know that karen has a solid grasp
of
earth and water release and yin and yang
release i'll also briefly mention
uzumaki number six karen's mom
who appears in the anime when karen was
still young her mother took her to
kusagakure the inhabitants let them stay
as long as cotton's mother
used her abilities to heal injured
villagers and this is where it gets
pretty dark
like cotton the mom possessed the
ability to heal those who bit her
and thus absorbed her powerful chakra
however the villagers overused her
ability and cotton's mother
eventually died from over exerting
herself then the villagers replaced her
with karen so when orochimaru came
around and offered to save her from that
situation you can understand why she
went along with him
next up we have uzumaki number seven
kushina ozumaki the mother of our
protagonist and the second jin churiki
of the ninetales
kushina was brought over from
uzushiogakure the home of the uzumaki
clan at a young age
so that she could enroll in the academy
and become the jinchuriki it was already
a tradition for uzumaki to be the
jinchuriki
as was the case with the first hokage's
wife and kushina was picked specifically
because of her powerful chakra which was
even strong among the uzumaki when
speaking about the first nine tails
jinchuriki mito kushina said
that she was the wife of the first
hokage so kushina the second nighttail
jinchuriki decided to be the wife of the
fourth hokage who was naruto's dad
minato namikaze
as a kid she proclaimed that she would
become the first female hokage but the
other kids just laughed at her and
called her tomato
because of her red hair and round face
she was a tomboy though and she would
beat up those who teased her
and so the nickname evolved from tomato
to the red hot blooded habanero
clearly she was strong to begin with
since she had especially strong chakra
that could potentially suppress the nine
tails and she could even beat up boys
without a problem
she then had the entire nine-tailed fox
sealed inside her which would have
boosted her already strong chakra even
more
not only was her uzumaki life force
strong enough to survive the nine tails
being extracted from her
she even went on to help minato pin down
the nine tails with her adamantine
ceiling chains as i mentioned when
discussing cutting these chains are made
of chakra and cuttings of the
sealing chains technique was only a
glimpse of what kushina was capable of
as mentioned kushna could dig her chains
into the ground and have them pop up so
that they'd trap the strongest of the
nine-tailed beasts
even in a weakened state she said she
could take the nine tails with her to
her death
although the tailed beast would
eventually re-emerge after a delay
the barrier she constructed with the
help of her chains to keep the nine
tails trapped inside
seemed to be so strong that even the
third hokage couldn't break through it
however he may not have broken through
it
because he didn't want the nine tails to
be able to escape
and not because he had no way of
breaking through it we don't know for
sure but i always tried to err on the
side of not underestimating sarutobi
like her clan
kushina excelled at ceiling jutsu and
even taught the fourth hokage minato
how to perform some she could use wind
water and yin release
eventually kushner died protecting her
son but it's clear that she
like minato was exceptionally strong so
naruto had op genes coming from both
sides of the family tree
and this is why some people argue that
rock lee would make for a better
underdog protagonist because naruto
clearly had incredible potential
from the start if you look at his
parents now let's talk about uzumaki
number 8
naruto uzumaki the legendary 7th hokage
himself
i already broke down naruto in my all 7
hokage and their powers explained video
link in the description so i'll keep
this section pretty short
like kushina kid naruto proclaimed that
he would become hokage and in his case
it came true he went from repeatedly
failing the academy exam as a kid to
being referred to as the strongest
shinobi in history
a pretty impressive zero to hero
transformation as an uzumaki a
reincarnation of asura
tsutsuki and ajin churiki at the nine
tails naruto has beyond massive reserves
of chakra and if all that wasn't enough
he also received chakra from all the
other tailed beasts
and from the sage of six paths which
further increased his power he even has
an artificial arm now made from
hashirama cells that can absorb ninjutsu
attacks
the only thing missing is sasuke giving
him his rinnegan naruto can now use
all five nature transformations and yin
and yang release some of his most
notable abilities include shadow
clothing to the extreme
every variation of the rasan gone you
can imagine including the s-class
technique
win release rasa shuriken the golden
naruto form known as six-path sage mode
which lets him flex on his opponents and
even summon a giant three-headed kurama
avatar
that can launch giant rasan shurikens oh
and we can never forget the sexy jutsu
and all of its versatile variations
like karen he can use his chakra to heal
people and even restore missing organs
and best of all
people don't need to bite him to get
healed so that's it for naruto in this
one
remember that you can check out the
seven hokage and their powers explained
video for a more detailed breakdown
next let's look at uzumaki number nine
boruto uzumaki the controversial figure
himself
here things get interesting because
naruto's family is pretty much the
remaining uzumaki clan
so even though the byakugan was not
initially a characteristic of the
uzumaki clan but of the hyuga clan from
now on those umaki clan descendants will
have the byaku god in their blood
so you can say that now it is a
characteristic of the clan
just something that i thought was pretty
interesting boruto is a prodigy and
clearly has good genes his father is the
strongest shinobi
and a descendant of the famous uzumaki
clan and son of the fourth hokage while
his mother
is a member of the famous huga clan more
on her later in the anime during the
ghanian exams kakashi suggested that
boruto was not only exceptional compared
to his class members he was also at a
tuning level
according to kakashi borto excels in all
areas like his father boruto has large
chakra reserves and good chakra control
being able to perform one-handed seals
he's said to have the potential for sen
jutsu meaning he could enter sagemo down
the line
like naruto he likes using shadow clones
that a sengon with his own vanishing
spin on it
and can even perform the much feared
sexy jutsu rather than wanting to be
like his hokage father
berto chose sasuke as his mentor and so
it makes sense that he can summon the
giant snake
garaga rather than a toad with some help
from sasuke
boruto became quite skilled in shuri
kenjutsu aka the art of throwing kunai
shuriken and other projectiles
he can even coat his shrutiken in
lightning speaking of lightning
boruto's natural affinity is lightning
release but he can also use wind release
and water release
then there's boruto's own op twist his
comma or
karma in the viz translation i'll be
using karma for the purposes of this
video his karma is a backup of momoshiki
ototuki
and it allows boruto to access otutsuki
powers the o2 care presented as godlike
in the naruto world
yotutsuki clan is the strongest clan so
this potentially gives borto the
possibility of eventually even
surpassing naruto when activated the
karma mark gives boruto a significant
boost across the board
and lets him absorb ninjutsu with
another karma user he can even create a
dimensional portal when pushed the will
of momoshiki can take control of boruto
kind of like how the nine tails would
take control of naruto in the past
in chapter 43 of the manga this form
lets borto fly
unleash massive rasengans and more it
allows him to straight up flex on the
powerful borrow then there's boruto
special eye the jogon meaning pure eye
in japanese
its power is associated with the
strongest of clans dotsutsuki it will
probably continue to evolve and perform
new abilities
but for now it can see the flow of
chakra track people based on their
chakra
allow one to see a person's chakra
pathway system and like the byakugan
identify its key points
and predict where your motsu hirasaka
aka the original space-time ninjutsu
used by the otutsuki clan
will be used and it makes sense that an
ototuki dojutsu
aki power can predict an otsutsuki's
space-time ninjutsu
i spent more time here on boruto than i
expected to but between the manga and
anime there is a lot of interesting
things to discuss about him but now i'm
ready to move on to uzumaki number 10
himawari uzumaki the daughter of naruto
and hinata and the little sister of
boruto she is two years younger than
boruto making her 10 years old during
the boruto movie himawari has clearly
got a lot of potential since she
awakened the byakugan at a very young
age
when she did so she scared boruto who
claimed that she was super strong all of
a sudden
it's a moment of comedic relief but she
ends up punching naruto in the gut so
hard that even kurama feels it
at 10 years old she learns to activate
the byakugan at will like other biakugan
users when it's activated himawari can
potentially gain access to an almost 360
degree field of vision
see across great distances and even
through solid surfaces
and as i mentioned with the drogon
perceive people's chakra pathways and
potentially close off their chakra
points
in one of the hitachi novels a biakugan
user could split chakra based jutsu and
remain completely unharmed the byakugan
also lets the user see if genjuts was
being performed on others
i remember personally thinking during
the early naruto days that the byakugan
was even cooler than the shoting gun and
i hope we keep learning new information
about it in boruto in addition to the
byakugan himawari can hit a bullseye
with ease
proving that she's already skilled at
churi kenjutsu and her natural chakra
control
unlike kid naruto's is impressive enough
that she can already temporarily stick
to vertical surfaces by focusing chakra
into her feet while her peers
fell immediately when they tried she
clearly has immense potential we just
gotta hope that she becomes a ninja
rather than a flower shop owner or
something else not
ninja related i'd love to see her
kicking butt alongside boruto in the
future
uzumaki number 11 was not born into the
uzumaki clan but married into it of
course
i'm referring to hinata hyuga the best
girl in naruto hinata used to be
regarded as a failure by her clan
the ogs will remember her fight against
neji
where he told her that a weak
personality won't become strong a
failure is always a failure
and all that negative jazz hinata lost
but fought bravely
showing she wasn't a weak person who
would give up or run from a fight
in one of the series most touching
moments she was even ready to die at
payne's hands
for naruto's sake one thing's for sure
she definitely proved neji wrong
with her biakugan hinata can see a
person's chakra pathway system and the
361 tenketsu which are nodes no larger
than the prick of a pin
using gentle fist style hinata can hit
these nodes and inject her own chakra
into her opponent
in order to halt the flow of that
person's chakra or enhance it
controlling it any way she wishes
through this fighting style hinata can
cause severe damage to any internal
organs
located near the attack chakra points
even though she started off as a
screw-up by adulthood she was highly
regarded for her mastery of the gentle
fist fighting style
thus all the things i already mentioned
about the byakugan when i spoke of
himawari
applies even more so to hinata who's an
expert whereas her daughter is still a
novice comparatively speaking
ninjutsu is not hinata's main focus but
she can use fire and lightning release
now things get really interesting just
like naruto and sasuke got some chakra
from hagoromo otsutsuki hinata got some
chakra from the sage of sixpath's
younger brother hamura otutsuki the
ancestor of the hugo clan
as a result she got a significant power
up and her chakra changed from blue to
purple
hamura even recognized hinata as the
byakugan princess which is a pretty
perfect name for the best girl
with this chakra upgrade she can
replenish naruto's insane chakra
reserves
in moments and she doesn't even look
drained afterwards
in contrast sakura took three days to do
the same and she was bedridden
afterwards
hinata can also see 20 kilometers in any
direction with her byakugan
in contrast we've only seen neji who was
previously referred to as the most
talented hyuga
use his biakuan to see as far as 800
meters
so hinata can potentially see 25 times
further
than the talented negi which is insane
to think about
at the end of the day hinata went from
being a failure in the eyes of her clan
to becoming the strongest huga
significantly surpassing even nedgie
she's more of a mom than a fighter these
days
but don't let that fool you she is the
perfect wife for naruto the strongest
shinobi in history not only are they
both strong
they both proved kidnejy wrong by
showing that even screw-ups can change
and even become the best finally uzumaki
number 12 is a movie-only character
called menma uzumaki he is pretty much
emo naruto from a fake genjutsu created
world where minato and kushina never
died
toby created this fake world and set
naruto and sakura in it by using a kind
of infinite tsukuyomi prototype called
the limited tsukuyomi
unlike naruto menma is a bad guy and
s-ranked criminal
he's like the venom to naruto spider-man
thus it makes sense that menma has
similar powers to naruto he's a
jinchuriki of the black ninetails he can
unleash the giant nine tails like a
summon he is also able to create nine
powerful masked beasts
using the nine tails chakra he has a
sort of dark rasangan
spiraling ring he can use a more
powerful version of this technique to
cause a giant bomb-like explosion that
completely devastates the hidden leaf
village
plus he needs no clones to use this move
he can also fly around freely and when
toby takes over his body he gains the
shotting gun
and the ability to use kamui which lets
him become intangible and use
teleportation
naruto still beats menma because it's
his movie and again jutsu world but it
was interesting to see an uzumaki and
nine tails jinchuriki
with a shotgun overall i did enjoy the
road to ninja naruto movie
where emo naruto made his debut and that
is it for this one i hope you enjoyed it
these videos do take a bunch of work but
i made this one because it was heavily
requested
andrew chiha video got 4 000 likes so if
you want to see another one
a obliterate that like button and b let
me know what video topic you would like
me to cover
next in the comments like last time when
this video hits 4 000 likes i'll get
started on one of the suggested videos
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial ring that notification
bell or you will miss future videos
while you wait for the next one to drop
check out my growing naruto playlist
where you can find videos about dochiha
hokage and more
lastly the youtube ad rates have dropped
big time so the support we're getting
from our anime outpour patrons
is very appreciated a very special thank
you goes to our patrons over on patreon
who help us survive these youtube issues
and who help make videos like this one
possible
first and foremost i want to thank are
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
atop
all clans stephen and grotta alola and
atem dill world steelers acquire respect
pate hepa
jonathan king brandon of isles papa
smurf the school bus king riser
emperor otaku ricardo martinez thomas
jones
ken mono michael hyde and jaden the
vector controller
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings eldris anatoly
kazotsky
angel crews cricket xp joe stanton very
gucci alicia actor jessica kayla fond
hinokami and water bonnie parks
zodiar 12 orthu and de ora kraken
aurel's
and deadly saint thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime poor link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the youtube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you